[Music]
hi there was a time when government
embraced Tick-Tock I want to say thank
you for staying at home it's easily the
most popular social media app amongst
young people the UK is passing some new
legislation to make the internet safer
for the younger generation and what
better way to get liked among millions
of them we dispatched an anthropomorphic
porcine Ambassador but not anymore we
are also going to ban the use of tick
tock on government devices the main
reason tiktok's parent company bike
dance is Chinese tiktok's ability to act
as a data trojan horse is Gravely
concerning and tackling techno
authoritarianism must be one of our
foremost priorities so Tick Tock is too
risky for ministers and officials to
have on their government-issued devices
but of all the apps on our phones it's
arguably no worse than other ones when
it comes to the amount of personal
information it has it knows who we are
where we are what device we're using
even our contacts and the content of our
messages
but so too do other apps like Instagram
Facebook and YouTube I think the the key
question with Tick Tock is actually more
about whether or not if the Chinese
government were to ask Tick Tock to turn
over its data whether Tick Tock would be
able or legally able to refuse that
request which I don't think we we
necessarily know I think we have
suspicions
um but I think that's the really key
question less about whether the
application is behaving in an unusually
aggressive manner try telling them that
today Net Zero secretary Grant chaps
posted on Tick Tock that he'd continue
using it on his personal device and it's
not clear if the band will have any
impact on millions of UK Tick-Tock users
I'm not leaving
the company today said it was
disappointed by the decision saying it
believes government bans in the EU the
US and now here are based on fundamental
misconceptions driven by wider
geopolitics
but is it just the beginning the Biden
Administration has threatened an
outright ban on Tick Tock unless it
sheds Chinese ownership
the UK has stopped short of that but can
the world's most popular video real app
persuade the West to keep on swiping or
is trust ebbing away
Tom Clark Sky News